[Music]
my name is I am Lithuanian by origin and
I work as an interpreter for the
European commission I've worked as a
staff interpreter for four years and a
bit
[Music]
now as an interpreter when we work at
the European commission we have a chance
to witness the decision-making process
the backstage of that and uh we see how
different opinions are brought together
brought closer to each other how
compromises are found and uh how it all
happens and we are part of this as we
are helpers in the communication we help
people to understand each other we
convey their ideas in other
[Music]
languages I like working at the European
commission for several reasons it gives
you a chance to use your skills in
different different areas me personally
I am an interpreter so my main task is
interpreting but I also have some um
teaching tasks uh I have a pedagogical
work as well I also participated in
organizing some events so it gives you a
possibility to have other uh tasks and
and functions not only your main one
which I think is wonderful another thing
is that you can learn quite a lot for
those who love languages in the European
commission they provide us with uh good
conditions for learning new languages
and also other things it helps you in
your personal development there are many
courses that you can choose from and uh
this I think is also very interesting
and useful and also in the European
commission you can get uh many options
to choose from in other areas in your
life such as your free time activities
sports facilities artistic companies
choirs um yoga classes is you name it
there are very many things to choose
from and when I started working here I
think uh this was one of the things that
I was the most surprised about that
actually they try to care about every
area of your life which I am really
grateful for and I think this is
[Music]
wonderful